only on CBS this morning the fiancee of
an unarmed woman killed by a former
Minneapolis police officer says he wants
police nationwide to learn from the case
Justine Damon died nearly two years ago
after being shot by Officer Mohamed nor
nor was responding to Damon's 9-1-1 call
last week a jury found nor guilty of
murdering Daymond Donn Damon spoke with
Jamie yuccas in his first sit down TV
interview following Moore's conviction
Jamie is outside government center in
Minneapolis Jamie good morning good
morning Don and Justine Damon were just
a month away from being married when she
died
Justine had already changed her last
name and uprooted her life in Australia
to join Don here in Minneapolis Don now
hopes her death will encourage this
Police Department and others to become
more mindful of officers conduct and
well-being
cannot even still get my arms around how
this could happen nearly two years after
Justine Damon's death her fiance Don
Damon is still grieving I'm coping but I
am one day at a time
Mohammad Noir is facing up to 15 years
in prison for shooting and killing
Justine a jury last week convicted the
former Minneapolis police officer of
charges including third-degree murder
what was going through your mind when
the verdict was read I broke down crying
it was the acknowledgment that what we
know is how tragic this is how wrong
this is
how unjust this was in what would be
their final conversations Justine called
Don on the evening of July 15 2017 while
he was in Las Vegas for business he says
she was concerned she had heard a
possible sexual assault near their home
my first thought was I want her to be
safe and so I said I think just stay put
and call nine one and then
back officer noir and his partner
responded to Justine's call while
searching for a suspect from inside
their patrol car noir testified that he
heard a loud slap on the driver's side
of the vehicle and shot Damon from the
passenger seat out of fear for his
partner's life and probably six seven
minutes later I text her having not
heard from her I said tell me what's
going on
at this point she was already gone the
case is not the first deadly police
shooting in Minnesota to gain national
attention oh my god please don't tell me
he's dead in 2016 Geronimo Llanes a
police officer in a st. Paul suburb shot
and killed 32 year-old falando Castile
during a traffic stop
a jury eventually acquitted in AZ of all
charges
inciting protests across the Twin Cities
this is a policing issue what changes do
you want to see I would like the
Minneapolis Police Department to go back
and consider what how officers are
trained I can understand where black
lives matter is so angry because you can
see the unjustified shooting across this
nation but this is a blue issue what I
can say is that we are exceedingly
committed to making change
Minneapolis city leaders including the
mayor and police chief acknowledge the
police department's training and
policies need improvement that's
probably the most important which is
outlined first and foremost in my vision
for the department moving forward is
sanctity of life
Damon hopes that progress isn't just
confined to Minneapolis how can what was
learned here be taken to change and
address policing in this country there
needs to be the changes made so that
this no one has to go through this that
no one ever has to experience what we
experienced Justine's family filed a
civil rights lawsuit seeking more than
50 million dollars from Minneapolis the
city made an unprecedented settlement
with the family for 20 million two
million of which will go to a fund aimed
at addressing local gun violence new
attorneys have not yet announced whether
they will appeal his conviction
Gail many people feel the way that mr.
Damon does we have to look at policing
in this country thank you very much
Jamie